one thing I was researching for my book
was you know what are the differences
between energizing relationships and
training relationships I love this
concept and one of the key things that
came up in in the in the studies that I
was looking at was
um
the idea of energizing responses
so for example if someone shares news
then there's sort of four different ways
to respond to that and the two main axes
for that are is it active or passive and
is it constructive or destructive
so active constructive is where we kind
of want to be for the most energizing
relationships which is you know you you
say you've just run a half marathon or
whatever and an active constructive
response might be oh my God that's
incredible tell me more about how did it
feel and it's like I'm building on it
and asking you to share more that's so
good a passive constructive response
would be oh that's cool yeah passive I
mean it's constructive in that I haven't
like torn you down for it but yeah it's
not that energizing it's sort of neutral
at best a passive destructive response
would be
um kind of
oh cool but let me tell you about the
thing that I did where it's like kind of
the self-center thing and then an active
destructive response is a total dick
where someone's like well that's not
such a big deal like blah blah blah blah
like why would you think you should do
that you're going to ruin your knees
that would just be a completely
unhelpful response yeah and shifting
more towards energizing interactions
active constructive responses to things
there's like genuine evidence from like
psychology studies that people who do
that are seen as more energizing more
charismatic more enjoyable to be around
than people that respond in any of the
other three ways it's so powerful isn't
it
um the one that you said uh it's active
uh no passive constructive is that it
where someone's like oh that's cool yeah
isn't that the worst
I honestly think that that's worse than
someone being like oh cool but guess
what I did I like and especially when
you share news with with friends or
family and I think those are the people
that we love the most and we trust the
most and we want them to be like really
in our corner but then you have to
remember that
the reaction that you want from someone
else you need to give them as well so
anytime someone gives you really great
news like you need like you should be
genuinely excited for them if they're
someone that you care about or someone
that you like or someone that you know I
think that's so valuable just
reciprocating yeah good energy from the
people that you want in your life is so
powerful in our ways
yeah the other the other tip that um one
of our team members actually shared with
me uh was you know something he's fun
really helpful is just a greeting
someone very effusively because if like
we hang out with a friend like I think
especially as dudes um I suspect it's
like you're kind of trying to play cool
like oh really you don't want to be too
keen and you don't want to come across
as like you know a bit too kind of
emotionally expressive and so you're
just like oh hey man how's it going
whereas like if I like oh my God God
went it's so good to see you it's been
so long like how are you like just
something like that makes the other
person feel great makes you feel great
it starts the interaction off on the
right foot like and it's a very easy
hack just like greeting people more
effusively than you think you should
um really helps to again make
relationships more energizing yeah and I
think sometimes think people think that
that's inauthentic and I don't think
that's the case
um I think it's just about tapping into
how you really feel about someone and
it's almost like adopting like a
labrador philosophy of like oh my God
I'm so excited to see this person and
even if you don't like you know you have
those days where you're like I'm so
tired I'm so tired and I really wanted
to cancel these plans but I haven't seen
this person in six months and a lot of
it is about like faking it till you make
it if you like are really if you act
really excited to see someone you will
feel excited to see them and they'll
feel excited to see you and then it's
like an amazing positive experience so I
really did believe in in that advice
that you just gave hey friends thank you
so much for watching if you enjoyed this
clip then click here for the full
unedited episode and if you like that
then do please consider subscribing to
the channel it means a lot thank you so
much and have a great day bye